tonight star is born qui nie mais
dominique
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est facile ça brille ça rayonne
et m'amuser du tennis en détresse ou
différemment les compliments premier
degré mais tu es très toile fait une
jolie fille en plateau bat et là c'est
tout à fait le boulot vous savez pas que
c'est pas mignon roman 2002 je vous sens
bien manger bien et d'ailleurs je le
remets présenter nos chroniques à bâle
mais faites comme chez vous mais comme
chez vous aussi je vais là-bas s'il vous
plaît pas duré longtemps mais tu as bien
ensemble et c'est par ici sur parmi nous
nous avons jean michel maire
[Musique]
bani walid
mais est-ce que je peux me permettre
d'enchaîner avec le prochain magnéto
écouter ça ne change rien à mon cas chez
les jaunes donc ça y est j'ai pris mes
marques
on m'a chargé le nouveau magnéto donc ce
sens les enfants en coupe donc voila moi
j'ai vu le magnéto tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment trop mignon et ouais comme quoi
les enfants tombent amoureux alors nous
non avec maxime et les enfants oui alors
regardez petit retour dans le passé pour
commencer avec ce reportage de
l'émission ça se discute dans lequel on
découvre deux enfants amoureux dans leur
quotidien je suis tout le temps du style
même que c'est lui qu'on qu'il était mon
but le plus culte dans cette émission
c'est le moment où le couple de jeunes
amoureux est interviewé par jean luc
delarue en plateau certainement une des
interviews les plus mignonnes mais les
plus compliqués à mener de la carrière
de l'animateur vous avez quel âge quand
vous êtes rencontrés tous les deux dès
qu'ils avaient deux ans moi j'avais au
moins 335
et vous allez voir le jeune homme est
très appliqué il répond scrupuleusement
à toutes les questions de l'animateur
peut-être un tout petit peu trop au pied
de la lettre
qu'est ce qui te plaît chaudière si
jamais ils ne sont sobres et comme
toujours c'est madame qui sauve la
situation
qu'est ce qui m'a plu chez n'y sommes à
cinq ans soit on dit chez olivia je
voulais dire je vais pas dire chez elle
je vais je voulais dire j'ai comment
dire et attention dans quelques instants
vous allez assister à la réponse la plus
sincère de la galaxie pourquoi te plaît
qu'elle me trouve très beau
le tour comment doit aller bien jeune et
voilà on sait maintenant pourquoi
l'expression la vérité sort de la bouche
des enfants est si populaire
on continue avec un mariage aussi
étonnant qu'angoissant et pas seulement
à cause de la coupe de cheveux du marié
à seulement 9 ans ces jeunes anglais
sont déjà mariés
bon le gard intérêt lui offrir une jolie
bague étant donné qu'il a visiblement
braqué une bijouterie et décider de tout
porter sur lui eux aussi c'est même très
fort malgré leur jeune âge gaspard et
son amoureuse dans je t'aime et c est ce
que tu veux te marier avec lui
[Musique]
allez on dieu on dit à demain un gros
bisou petit jeu maintenant sur cette
image
essayez de deviner lequel des deux
amoureux elle est un peu moins que
l'autre
moi je compte
messieurs il faut arrêter là la personne
à votre gauche n'aime visiblement pas
trop vos approches alerte info les
petites figurines des mariés qui se
trouve sur la pièce montée se sont
échappés visiblement elles vivent un
amour idyllique loin de leur gâteau
voici maintenant l'image d'un joli
couple de bébés non pardon c'est un
trouble apparemment et pour finir dans
c'est mon choix vous allez voir un
garçon passer d'une relation amoureuse à
la fredzone tu lui as déjà dit j'attends
mathaliens est ce que ça t'a fait quand
il a dit je t'aime bas c'était marrant
ailleurs allez courage
et comme on dit une de perdue bas une de
perdue
[Applaudissements]